hello playwatch listeners alana here i'm
actually not on this episode and the
boys forgot to record the video
so i think this is our first episode
since episode one
where we don't have video it is what it
is
enjoy you were commenting on my
pettiness i believe i was you want to
tell the listeners what you what you
call every file for a larger i
had pitched two years ago
uh is it two and a half years ago
wow it's been 20 years yes
i had pitched
um
a
vague simpson reference up and adam
where adam is aatm for austin alana troy
mike
and i was summarily
dismissed in fact i don't even think
that name was
put to put to the floor for debate
and um i think me and troy vetoed it
because our letters were at the end and
we just that was unacceptable that was i
didn't or you guys wouldn't allow that
yeah i i i mean look i get it but
point being that every file name of my
independently recorded audio has been
aatm for a hundred and however many
episodes now
in silent protest of the uh decision now
vocal protest
now vocal process now canonically part
of the show process yep exactly
so i would appreciate it if the comments
all
rallied to my cause and referred to the
show as aatm
watch this get it get edited out yeah
that's it's good it's good
the metrics gonna be solid hey
um yeah they didn't get any of my audio
then that's great
that's good that'll be the audio the
listener will be able to imagine what
you the listener in response
hello listeners stephen hey listener
how's it going hello you're right hold
on
a second i guess that's me but i'm a
listener
i um first time listener 160 episodes
part of the show yes
that's a nice reverse ratio first time
listener 107th time caller
yeah never listen
i just asked my question off the air
um
i
just got back from tejas
texas to the layman
uh
and
i don't know like i can tell because of
the hop the hot gives you away yeah this
hat gave me away
um this hat gave me a way to anyway uh i
don't know if you guys have like because
i mean
for all intents and purposes mike you're
you're a little bit further away from
where you grew up but not by much
um i mean nothing's far from anything in
this country in fairness yeah you're 30
minutes away either by train or by the
car or by walking
um
but like austin for you for denver i
i had forgotten there's like these these
three things that are just instantly
texas summer
humidity
um no it's cicadas
uh fireflies and bluebell ice cream like
those three
ingredients
make the most nostalgic we're just
sitting there bluebell ice cream
bluebell ice cream is something that is
if anybody is watching in texas
especially dallas there's two things
that are that are just dallas staples
and it's bluebell bluebell homemade ice
cream
um
is you can only find is i mean it's
indigenous and i think limited to texas
they don't ever send them out anywhere
but it's just the best i've been in
jerry's and all of that no can't even
hold a candle and especially
to the blue bell um ice cream sandwiches
those things are just
heaven a little slice of heaven but the
cicadas wait wait was the second you
said though you said oh sorry the two
things uh a blue bell and then mrs
barrett's bread so just off of
mockingbird in 75
uh was a big you know it started off
really really small and then hostess was
like the national competitor this was
its homegrown thing
but if you drove past the
uh factory that was just off of central
expressway i think it was mockingbird in
75
um which is also central expressway if
you drove by right this at the perfect
moment in the morning which i did drive
when i worked downtown
you could smell them baking the bread
and it was so
strong that even in your car driving 75
miles an hour on the freeway it just
filled the air
um so that reminds me of cold winter
mornings
because the season that i worked in
dallas was was during the winter the
presumably heavenly experience of
passing through the the baking cloud
mm-hmm
and you could always smell it i would i
it was just an it's a it's a sounds
unmistakable scent
but yeah the
the cacophonous
summer sounds of of the cicadas and just
how they undulate together and then
break apart and get louder and get
quieter and then the fireflies i was
like man i had forgotten about fire me
of all people forgot about fireflies
well you have a you have a difficult
relationship with fireflies i do it's a
little conflicted but traveler was like
what the hell is narratively interesting
though like there's depth to it it's
good yeah there it is yeah what anyway
what was his reaction to the fireflies
he just was trying to write was like
wait a minute i was like dude those are
bugs he was like what i was like we call
them lightning bugs or fireflies
and he was like
and he was like can i go chase him and
and my brother-in-law tim goes uh
there's another insect that's very prone
to uh or uh uh indicative of texas which
are chiggers and he was like you don't
want to go back in there right now those
are the worst
well just experienced it
she she ran through the field she's like
i'm having so much fun it's so beautiful
back here i was like
well
they're like they're like mosquitoes but
you can't swat them so you just end up
with your skin all irritated and you
don't know like a mosquito you know
instantly you got bit a [ __ ] she's
like go home and then it's gonna hit pam
has 30. she looks like she just walked
into a bee's nest i was like bring it on
what do you want to do
it's so and it's the worst itch too and
it's a mosquito bite can kind of i'll go
away in a dare to these sugar bites last
so i just didn't know for you guys if
you have anything that's that indicative
doesn't not necessarily the summer
season but
you're like oh if i smell this hear this
see this i'm instantly transported back
to
my hometown
i'll take my answer off the air i uh i
mean i i grew up in brighton so the
answer to that question is probably not
suitable for the podcast but uh yeah
whenever i smell
meth being made yeah
human suffering
um no i mean yeah the seawater like i
mean
the sea water for me whenever i get back
to brighton it's always the whatever the
water see what the uh that salt that
salty air yeah that's that's the that's
the ticket
immediately transports me back
funny enough
uh
my grandparents were
both um
well my mom mostly but but the whole
family's from the south arkansas also
had
the cicadas and the
uh fireflies and and you know the
[ __ ] poison ivy and all the other
stuff that uh that we did not have in
colorado colorado being so dry most of
these things we did have cicadas uh did
you yeah that's just a holy south thing
no they definitely have them up in the
for like proper forests in the mountains
right um
and but i but they they're real loud and
aggressive in the south and i associate
that with visiting my grandparents so i
have a similar
nostalgia
first time i first time i ever saw
firefly was probably
slightly older but
comparable to your traveler story where
i was visiting my grandfather in
arlington
and
he had a little garden you know he had
probably a good solid one-acre
plot i would guess maybe a little less
than that
um but it felt like a lot of land
because the house was also pretty small
so there was a big garden and a big
backyard
and but then there was a little creek
and there was all this poison ivy and
stuff that would grow around by the
water but at night you'd see the little
flashes and um i remember i we drove
uh like in a minivan there and it was
gonna take a couple days to get back
home and
i i don't know how old i was but
probably
six or seven or eight
but i remember catching one
and putting it in a jar
and then trying to basically see if it
would light up right in front of me
which of course i'm pretty sure it
immediately died um and it was a big
fail but i was sitting there holding it
like any moment anymore for like the for
like the day and a half
ride back i don't think i've ever seen
one hearing you talk about it i think
it's one of those things i've only i saw
my first hummingbird a few weeks ago
because i i grew up in the uk like i was
in disneyland and there was a
hummingbird just kind of kind of came in
and it was doing the
hummingbirds flying i was like oh my god
i've never actually seen one of these
obviously seen them in videos and
same with fireflies i don't think i've
ever seen a firefly we have we have to
come to our house here we have like tons
of hummingbirds we just have a lot of
things that attract them so that we have
a lot of hummingbirds but fireflies same
thing it's a very interesting experiment
because what we would do is we would get
a big mason jar punch holes in the top
of it and then we'd run around outside
and it's it's always just right dusk
like that's when you want to do it
and you huh i probably didn't punch the
holes in there
if you listen to take one thing from
this episode oxygen it's good it's a
good thing yeah even for you
we would put we would put the uh we
would try to fill them up and you could
get a pretty good amount and then you
seal them in there but what's
interesting is is they don't do that in
captivity essentially
they only they won't light up um so you
i think aren't they doing it kind of as
a social behavior like has to be i'm
sure somebody's going to go oh actually
what that is is it's a response to i
can't wait
it's usually it's mating or
hating right usually like usually an
animal's going to do get away or come
here yeah exactly like those look at me
or go away
i i do feel like because i i feel like
i've never seen
i don't have a memory of seeing like one
random one it would be along the tree
line or whatever
they just kind of dot the whole
field of view almost and and so
i feel like it's not necessarily
communication but yeah like a mating
display i have no idea let's i'll i'll
be alana and google it all right it is
very interesting because i don't know if
you've ever heard of speaking of texas
uh phenomena the the marphilites
which are the the mysterious ghost
lights of marfa uh out in southwest
texas there's a little town called
martha that's known for two things
number one
i believe it's a someone's going to
correct me i think it's an hermes store
or it's a gucci store that was actually
done as kind of like an art installation
piece but it's actually a fully
functioning store it's like if you look
and again if it's arames it's like
london paris tokyo l.a martha texas it's
just like the most random
you have to take left
you're right there at that uh you'll see
a possum in the road that's phil and
then just keep about a quarter mile
you'll see it um but there's these ghost
lights that if you park your car just
off the highway
which is like a two-lane highway
way off in the distance
just along the the horizon
this time of night you'll see these
lights just like these orbs that will
light up and they'll go up and they'll
move and i mean everyone has tried to
get out there and the closer they get to
them the further they move
and
there's no explanation they say like
they've no they've never explained
something like a marauder no idea but i
mean it is you you will look and you'll
be like
what is that and it's like
is it is it gas or obviously there's
some explanation to it but until you see
it
it's uh
it's it's something to see but it
fireflies are very much the same way
because trying to get to them they
always feel like wow fellas right there
they're like actually just a little bit
further away
so i googled why do fireflies glow tell
us yup i like that immediately google
doesn't understand the difference
between how and why because it goes
fireflies produce light in a special
organ in their abdomen by combining a
chemical called
luciferin
which is fun enzymes called luciferases
and oxygen um and metal
and the fuel for cellular work atep so
it's essentially a chemical reaction
that releases light that is not
why they do it that's how they do it so
i clicked on the scientific american
article
and honestly this whole thing is
fascinating so check this out go
um they produ this is our new show by
the way austin
without alana here as the video game uh
sort of no one's here
there is someone still watching for
video game insight so they're very
displayed but that's one person any
second they're going to talk about
kojima
so they produce a chemical reaction
inside their bodies that allow them to
light up this type of light production
is called bioluminescence the method by
which they do it is best known is a is
perhaps the best known example of
bioluminescence when oxygen combines
with calcium and atp and the chemical
luciferin in the presence of luciferase
a bioluminescent enzyme
light is produced unlike a light bulb
which produces a lot of heat in addition
to the light a fireflies light is cold
light without a lot of energy being lost
to heat this is necessary because if
they if their light organ got as hot as
a light bulb they would not survive um
they're able to control so they burn out
really quickly as well because obviously
they're tiny so they're energy reserves
yeah they're like [ __ ] tired
a firefly controls the beginning and end
of the chemical reaction
by adding oxygen to other chemicals
needed to bruise it this happens in
their light organ i just love the idea
of there being a light organ
when oxygen is available the light organ
lights up my favorite electronic advance
uh
because they don't have lungs and
instead transport oxygen from outside of
the body to the interior cells within
through a complex series of successively
smaller successively smaller tubes known
as tracheals for a long time it was a
mystery as to how they would manage such
a high flash rate considering the
relatively slow speed of the muscles
that control oxygen and transport
researchers fairly recently learned that
nitric oxide gas the same gas that is
produced by taking the drug viagra plays
a critical role in firefly flash control
in short when their light is off no
nitric oxide is being produced in this
situation oxygen that enters the light
organ is bound to the surface of the
cell's energy-producing organelles
and is thereby not able to transport
further within the light organ
um
they appear to light up for a variety of
reasons the first one it lists is
it's a defensive
mechanism because they produce
they produce steroids that uh make them
unpalatable to predators this is a very
chemically interesting insect
what's up you like
steroids and lucifer that's the thing
i was looking for the one sentence
takeaway and i just kept glimpsing i was
like i gotta read this whole thing so i
love that
they're
they're uh they they basically taste
terrible to predators
and so the the the light is essentially
a reminder
hey this is going to be unpleasant for
you so don't do it
discovered by anton levay founder of the
satanic church
also definitely tried to eat one this is
also interesting at some point someone
someone must have tried d1 if they can
categorically say in scientific american
that they taste bad that means well two
predators i'm not sure that the writers
for scientific american are necessarily
the natural predators but it's it's
someone in history had some yeah it's
like i think it's the luciferian stuff
that's just tastes like comments because
you can try some jelly yeah
it tastes like um an aging metal head
yeah it's a little better with the jelly
considering everything that we've
already discovered
like eels and lobsters you're definitely
right that someone has tasted everything
at some point and those which are not
part of our regular diet clearly
scientific methods the bravest humans
were the ones that go all right [ __ ] it
i'm gonna eat it
at some point everything was weird he's
like gary you're not actually going to
eat that cow or he was like dude i'm
hungry and that looks really well worse
than that is the first guy who
discovered that you could eat drink
cow's milk yeah like that's a
conversation that was a long that's a
conversation
ah [ __ ] i think i'm gonna drink it no it
does
i'm gonna squirt it in my mouth
don't do it jim don't do it no you don't
have to no i i think it might work oh
it's good oh [ __ ] it i love it yeah it's
pretty good i'm stuck now yeah i'm
always convinced that it was i whipped
it up some salt and now i made butter oh
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh no i felt the entire i'll leave
it again
i'm gonna leave it out overnight oh [ __ ]
my yogurt
put it in the freezer put it in the
freezer agriculture as a concept exists
entirely to cover up for a dude you
decided to do something gross to okay my
society happened all of those were the
same guy yeah it had to have been
and it's a guy did not date there was
nothing else if that guy
if one if one person on this quiet guy
had shown him just an ounce of love we
would be all lactose free we would never
we'd still be in the caves we'd still be
the guys like if just one person looked
at me in the right way and just smiled
and offered me their hand i would never
have made cheese
[Laughter]
how history would be different oh all
right i got a couple more for you go
ahead
uh there are different species of
fireflies and they flash different ways
and that's how they tell each other
apart as being different species it's a
signaling
to like
steve
[ __ ] sorry gary
gary that's it
i [ __ ] love that i think that's so
interesting that's great
hey dude i'm not gary
my name is actually jason
that's a physical comedy show guys who
is this yeah no we're we're we're doing
that we started recording this is good
content
let me press record
let's change settings
do i want to update i guess i'm just
gonna do a real quick windows update
i'll be uh oh good
much appreciated i have i have a video
game question all right go for it here
go new time stamps hard left turn has
anybody played shredders revenge
no i saw that it was really good
i saw that it was like
crushing it on steam it seems like it
would be good for you you're a big
arcade fan
it is like it's taken me back to the
only thing is it's it's um you ca i just
beat it last night you can play it by
yourself
uh but it is definitely be
made to be
like it's a it's a
side scroller beat them up grab your
friends and the cool thing is you it
constantly prompts you do you want to
party up to where you can go online and
actually find other people and do that
but it would be so much fun in
because this you know what happens with
those like whether it be like battle
toads or or tmnt like turtles and time
or whatever where it just or marvel vs
capcom was a good example too it's just
the screen became chaos of everybody
doing as many commas as they could to
fill up their power meter and then doing
their super move they're special and
it's just like the almost so much of the
graphics of the video just like cranking
down on it it's that frame rate just
sign a dip below 60. yeah
oh no it's a french developer they're
fairly small um and they just went for
it they were like we want this to feel
as if this thing was made in like 94 or
95
and it's so good they got the og cast
back back on it um
even even the way that like the bosses
die you know they would do that one
thing it was just they would just reuse
a frame of animation to where they're
just
yeah like that they do that it's just
like like a firefly trying to yell at
someone that's exactly what it is i i
mean literally the same thing towards
such a long setup for that payoff hey
man i'm sorry are you are you paul
paul we me and troy planned this for
heaven paul this is the whole thing oh
[ __ ] man i'm sorry dude doug hey dog
it's me yeah it's greg
all the people playing that's cool that
is revenge don't understand that they're
just going why is it also right holders
for like for like getting that for
letting a small team do something really
creative with the ip that's always
really cool when you see
you know that kind of thing happening
totally unlicensed
well seeing how long before uh how long
before they get taken down from steam
and then disappear shredder is not
unlicensed that's the whole thing is
it's like nickelodeon is is like signed
on it's legit yeah so that was that that
that was that was an example of humor
for those in the back oh sorry i got it
yeah you just sucked what you do is if
you're going to do humor it needs to be
built around fireflies as a concept
austin that's kind of what we're doing
it's all firefly jokes i'm here for the
firefly hard science y'all are the
jokers so
i am here for the cow joke so that i'm
down with
okay i'm curious mike because it's a
small team it's and i believe it could
be it could be a uh uh french canadian
team so forgive me i i haven't looked
them up yeah uh but just a lot of french
names on the credits i was gonna say you
saw a lot of flicks over the
oxen club
um i i like i like reading the credits
partly because i wanted to see if they
did get the og cast and they did
um but also just i wanted to see how big
the team was i wanted to see um like if
it was typically indicative and what's
what i've seen lately post covid is that
um
that is a very the the the names are
just so
varied because they're pulling from all
sorts of places like there's oh yeah
people that are able to work for a
company like i've never been there
before i'm in poland but they're in you
know montreal or whatever
um i bet with a game like that as well
you seek out the great pixel artists you
seek out the people yeah around the
world who are the perfect fit for that
it's such a specific thing you're trying
to evoke with that game i bet you go to
like the dude over here who's great that
the woman over here who's great at that
and just kind of pulled them together
montreal
what do you think the budget for that
is do you do you think it's just like a
holy [ __ ] we've got to hit on our hands
or do you think they knew
going in this this will absolutely smash
it
um
i'm you never know but i i suspect i
mean the numbers would have been good
because you've got you you obviously
when you think through ninja turtles in
the game space those the only game
because there's been lots of licensed
teams in hbo the only game you think of
is turtles in time right yeah so
i can see i can definitely see that
pitch like that's a straightforward
pitch just to go in and be like hey do
you know that one turtles game that
everyone loves we want to make basically
a sequel to that so yeah the budget
would have been reasonable pixel art's
more expensive than everyone realizes so
it would have been a bit pricier really
oh big slot's so expensive to do it
right yeah yeah i would always think
that that would be like hey it's low pro
so therefore it's cheaper but i mean i
think about this it's it's a lot easier
to do an electronic record than it is to
do a lo-fi analog record because you're
talking about actual musicians actually
very similar okay well remember when
you're making if i'm making if i'm
making a 3d game i'm making a free game
i'm making an uncharted i'm making uh
whatever aaa kind of game go for it
whatever i i pay a lot of money to make
art a main character oh joel i'm mixing
up my naughty dogs to make a character i
spend a lot of money my 3d model has to
be beautiful obviously beautifully
rendered sure i have to hire a great
actor to play him i have to
you know rig it up i have to do a bunch
of work but once i've done that work
once i've got that character the actual
creation of content with that character
is pretty cheap i have to animate it i
can make new animations but if i need to
move the camera around i can do this
that's cheap
it's really cheap it's with it's all
really cheap because you've basically
spent a lot of money on an asset and
then you can just use that asset with
pixel art
you're doing frame by frame by frame
there's no if i've got my pixel art
character and i'm like you know what for
this scene i want to move the camera
over here
what do you or i want to move the camera
closer to the carry if you're sticking
to that pixel art ratio if you want to
move the camera in you got to you got to
blow it out or there are some
interesting there's some people who are
playing with pixel art and recoloring of
pixels and doing really clever stuff
with that there's some very cool to
substitute lighting
to substitute lighting costume changes
and texture that kind of thing there's
some really clever tech and a lot of
stuff is done like that there's also a
lot of people who are doing a really
good job of rendering 3d to look like
pixel art so um dead cell is a good
example of that dead cells isn't pixel
art that'll there's there is pixel art
in there but like the character in dead
cells is a 3d model being rendered and
put through some processors look like
pixel that game as a side note is just
so great
it's so great so okay here's here's
where it lost me and i i fully admit
that it's not a flaw of the game it's
100 me
i
mean i'm so picky i want easy barrier to
barrier of entry
with a gradual climb up
and that game is not from the very onset
it is like
here's your sister
i was like your head against the wall
until you get yeah yeah 100 i was like
which i mean like like you know dungeon
crawlers or you know castlevania-esque
kind of games i
that's not what i grew up playing that
that wasn't the thing that i loved
prince of persia though i loved so i
definitely love figuring out those
mechanics but prince of persia was just
so wholly different karatek or kung fu
master all those i could really get down
but for some reason like castlevania i
was like ah [ __ ] i need to go back and
open that chest but i had to go through
the gauntlet of everything that i just
did i didn't like that did you play
hades i can't remember if you ever
actually played it i know i did i never
finished it and that is nothing to do
again with the game it was just like
i was playing it on my switch and
because it that i i was another game
that's 3d pretending to be 2d which is
really clever again yeah but it's it's
actually what's it called iso
isometric isometric camera yeah it's but
it's it's not a lot of their previous
games have been lots of 2d painted uh
character art with that one i think the
characters are 3d but again like just
rendered to look the art and the music
and the concealer i thought it was was
flawless it's literally a flaw and the
gamer not the game as far as like why it
didn't hold my attention not that it
didn't hold my attention but it's just
like ah that's the one i would play
right now because typically if i'm if i
have my switch
it is i'm either taxi takeoff and
landing or i'm in a hotel room and so i
have i don't have necessarily
the time that that those games to me
demand to be able to play it's like i've
got 15 that's why mario kart is just so
great it's an investment you're making
with a game like that for sure yeah like
the same reason i've still not gone to
elden ring and i
i might never that's just that but i
feel like such an investment but that's
the strength of dead cells and and um
haiti's both is that um it's realistic
to sit and have a 15-minute run and then
if you just do if you just do one i can
see where troy i can see where troy's
coming from it's intimidating don't get
me wrong i play in that way but like
that first time you sit down with it
like you probably don't want to spend
you don't want to you're not playing
that first session it's not 15 minutes
once you've gone into its rhythms you're
you're then there but i i can see why
that genre puts put some folks off it's
awesome
but i get it the reason why that first
session could be 15 minutes is because
you fail as opposed to achieved even
though
it is very much of that roguelike kind
of thing to be like that's part of the
thing where you die and you get better
but i was like [ __ ] i failed it's like i
like the
uh
shredder's revenge was perfect because
each
episode
um was about anywhere from seven to 12
minutes
and there were a few that i was like
[ __ ] i died on this and i'm playing like
on the i'm playing on the lowest level
because
traveler and i could play it and he was
so into it because it's mainly a button
masher you can do some super moves if
you want to but because of mario kart
he's learned is like hey dude these let
you do your specials and so he can
understand like
i'll just tell you your special is like
boom x or boom y and he can he can do
that but for us to be able to play a
game together it was
so much fun and that's the thing that i
do love about the switch is that even
though it was a big hold out for it to
go from here to here
great it's amazing yeah but there might
especially for someone like you that
travels so much exactly just pick up my
game throw it in the dock yeah but i i
found out about it because i
travel was like i want to play a new
game i was like alright see what's on
the store and there's like pre-orders
like oh pre-order
boom and it was like
for tomorrow like i had not seen
any marketing for this thing so i just
can't think that they were like
it felt like the inside even though or
maybe even more like a limbo
to where a little studio that could puts
out a good game and then the the
industry goes now you're a hit as
opposed to
a shitload of money being thrown at it
for marketing um but those are just so
few and far between i just didn't know
what your thoughts i also would love
austin to know what your thoughts of the
music are not that that's the limit of
your uh
perspective i'm allowed to speak on
but it definitely did a great thing with
with the music as far as
like uh uh example of it here
ghost kill is on there doing like it's
it's pretty cool who
you're selling me on that you're selling
it's so good man there's a lot of people
that are talking about it right now and
with good reason i just i hope somebody
on the team hears this
and they're a montreal base by the way i
don't know if you heard i had a feeling
yeah i was it was either paris or
montreal but i i figured it was montreal
i just hope somebody listens and and
hears the praise because it's it's
it's a super super fun game and it's
just executed
wonderfully wonderfully and it reminds
me of those they don't get people who
make the games the the people who make
the games it's not like [ __ ] donald
trump people who make the pixel art
games like they don't get
um no it's a real like it's a very sl
it's like stop-motion animation it's
like it is the least efficient way of
making video games but the artistry is
fascinating like the the the talent and
skill and
like i said there are people working on
trying to make it more cost efficient um
but it's one of those things that's just
yeah it's it takes a lot of time
if i make an animation for a 3d
character i can remap that to a
different character so what do you think
they're definitely different kinds of
enemies
without playing it of course i
understand but i mean
sure
like a pixel up ruler i mean it it
honestly comes down to like how many
artists they had working on the
animations and sprites and stuff like
that i don't imagine it was technically
a very complex game except i guess the
multiplayer component would probably
have been yeah a fair amount of work and
it's unique fighting styles to each
it's so it's not like everybody's
punching punching punching it's like
everyone has the reason why you play
leonardo because he has
specific skills that raphael doesn't but
the whole point of it is to squad up
and you can play as april you could play
a splinter you could play as a secret
character that i'm not going to talk
about until after you beat the game it's
awesome um
everything is unique and it's show it's
on joe
all right i'm endorsed by the developer
for the first quarter of the game
it just gets really sad
no turtles game would ever make you cry
you're welcome
i i know april dies
april times
splinter dies yes this is bad
no kudo kudos to the team kudos to was
it nickelodeon i think has turtles now
like oh yeah skills to them for giving
them the space to do it yeah it just
sounds like a cool i definitely that's
the kind of license game i want to play
this is just cool execution on on an
iphone music is great too the studio has
made um
a
bunch of other games and
um the
a few of them are in that you know
reasonably successful
like in the 200 to 500 000 units on
steam spy uh
uh they have several others pretty
that's pretty substantially impressive
for modern indie studios yeah they have
crude oils they have three in that in
that range i definitely have heard of
one of these called panzer paladin i
have no idea why i heard of that i never
played of it but i remember
someone that i
that i was talking to mentioning it so
they've definitely they've shipped a
bunch of games
can i
can i just comment on something that you
just said that i i really feel is
important um that those who listen or
watch uh understand because i just
became aware of this and maybe some
people already were because i know
there's a lot of people from the
industry that listen to this and maybe
they're standing up and going thank you
it's probably a commonplace assumption
to think that most people know that sure
not every game does this but
for the most part whenever a game is
sold whenever it's offered on a platform
like steam or multi-consoles whether it
be xbox or playstation or switch
that it just automatically is making or
selling rather
millions of copies
at least a million copies oh far from it
but something that you just pointed out
which is very
200 to 500 000 units sold
is a we're making another game level of
success
more than that yeah that's a six that's
a that's uh that's so let's get some
champagne success yeah indies nowadays
like back in the day 2012 there was a
time so when thomas was loan came out it
wasn't you were guaranteed a million
units but you were guaranteed like it
was it was it was called the money hoes
back then steam like all the indies
caught it was like if you were making
indie games getting on steam was a
massive deal like it only happened to a
few of us and when that happened it was
the money hose was pointed at you and
you were kind of guaranteed a level
success those days are gone like that
that made the change for a studio coming
through now is it just sheer
like there's two the landscape is too
filled or what is it loads of things
more more games um the pc
moving into a different place yeah
there's just there's lots of reasons for
it but it but it was just it is
definitely like now yeah 200 to 500 000
units for an indie kind of company with
a game that's not got like a major
publisher backing it marketing wise good
on them that's great by my napkin math
if you shipped their games all fall in
the broadly 20 range a little less than
that um
a quarter million units sold
after steam's 30 take is over 3 million
in revenue
um depending and and their games are
looks like one every 18 months that
they're shipping again so you're falling
so you're falling into a couple of traps
there that i feel gt bound by those same
developers troy mentioned to kind of
point out i'm not calling that profit
i'm saying i'm saying
gross revenue purely from steam's take
before you talk about any publisher
agreement before you talk about any
obviously
it ain't three million how okay so where
does that money go i mean there's also
refunds where we're purely speculating
you're the majority so i obviously and
this is true steamspy the numbers on
there my number's definitely wrong
there's lots of numbers on there that
are wrong i just made up a number 350k
but what i'm saying well the key thing
that's that people often miss like if
you read steamspine it said 250k or
whatever it said 200 to 500 000. so i
went low within that range yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and just so i know first
of all spy is an actual number because
it is sell in as opposed to or it is
sell through as opposed to sell in
meaning
the way it tracks the numbers is a bit
flawed so sometimes it can massively
over underestimate but let's say that's
the real number and austin's right to
lowball it that makes sense
what you're forgetting is the vast
majority of games are sold at discount
and often by a drastic discount so like
a steam sale
[Music]
some indies stay high but most of us
these days will often be dipping in and
out of sales so if you're looking at
someone's uh like sale number from
steamspy unfortunately that sum of like
let's multiply this number by thirty
dollars
i mean
if you if you look there are ways of
finding this out if you look at like
what their lowest like what was the
lowest they ever went on a discount you
can assume that the majority of those
half of the sales you're seeing were at
that price right so it's uh it's
that's the one that i think uh like
because you often see gamers like go on
to steam spy and look at that and
come up with numbers they're very big
which makes perfect sense but then you
remember oh no but like so thomas was
alone for example it's ten dollars and
it sold two and a half million units i
didn't make 25 million dollars from that
game right
you know it's like it's it's because
humble bundles because as i say humble
actually
added to steam spikes
yeah and that all counts so here's the
question so it's uh it's often uh
what i would suggest generally or what's
good if you want to use things like
steamspy and if you're making games you
you should probably be looking at the
marketplace and going oh what's this
always compare like for like so then
it's not useful to try and work out how
much money this company's game made but
if you were thinking of making a game in
a similar genre you could look at 10
games in that genre and start to use
those numbers to make comparison
comparisons and kind of
comparing is usually better than just
coming trying to arrive at a number okay
so here's filtered in the same way
something that i feel is important to
point out then let's just i'm not going
to say that this is what this shredder's
revenge budget was but let's let's say a
game on steam that's going to be in that
indie space that's going to hopefully
sell
our our median figure made up number of
250 000 copies let's just say that their
budget
is
two to two and a half
million yeah that means that most likely
even though they're a success they're
not profitable
um
well then you get into a few things of
first off i assume it came out on other
platforms other than steam so you've got
all those other platforms as well
stacking up okay so you've got a long
tail which that game will be sold on
multiple times sure over the next five
years or whatever when the publisher is
looking at that going how did we do
what's our opening weekend essentially
um
how because most people are going to buy
it day one or at least hopefully within
the first month of window maybe some
people would wait for a steam sale or
whatever but then again you're dipping
into that
my question is
does a publisher go
where it's it's not about making a game
it's about establishing an ip so that we
can extrapolate and do
shredders revenge two shredders revenge
five and turtles and you know
is that the hope of it or is it
literally this game has to be profitable
or is it this game needs to be
successful are those it's not a
one-size-fits-all it's not
one-size-fits-all they're they're again
they're up so so a publisher
many publishers have published games
they knew wouldn't be profitable because
they knew they'd be like critical
darlings so it raises the quality of the
brand it can do that definitely
publishers
my games have yeah exactly exactly the
same as moscow movie like they've
they've put out those kind of games
really don't think they're gonna make
profit often it's to establish an ip
like you say so they take maybe a bit of
a hit on the first one but to be honest
if you take a bit of a hill on the first
one maybe you don't want to invest more
money into a sequel anyway so your ip
kind of falls and dies there there's
weird stuff so like for example like i
don't know if this turtles game was in
game pass
i have no idea i've just covered the
entire if they were like theoretically
if they were
that could have covered their entire dev
budget just like that i'm curious to see
where the major possible publishers
yeah sometimes publishers are not
actually and this is going to be
something that's definitely going to
grow over the next few years
and this is definitely true of
developers already when we're thinking
about future projects like
the player you know the the
the individual listening to this
isn't
is the customer in the extent of i want
to make games to entertain that person
but in terms of the customer in terms of
who's paying
my company it's a publisher it's often a
platform holder if we're about to hit
like there's going to be a game pass on
every platform if i'm making a tv show
for netflix i'm making something that i
want to be popular with an audience
obviously but my customer is netflix i'm
selling to them right and i think that's
something we're going to see more and
more of of like you know potentially
the games i make in the future will be
paid by platforms and to an extent it
won't matter how many units they sell as
long as that platform continues to think
that my games are worth putting on their
platform you know what i mean so it's
it's we're potentially about to
transition into a service model where
my direct connection to the end consumer
is broken and that can that can lead to
some bad outcomes you know that can lead
to
complacency that can lead to shows
getting cancelled two seasons and it
despite uh audience who loves it you
know it can lead to very strange
stuff with and if if we're not careful
with games we could fall into some traps
with that austin for you as someone who
you work differently than me i i've i've
worked to try to make my you know ha
earn a seat at the table that's a little
bit closer to the big kids table as
opposed to just being an actor that gets
hired to come another to the booth of
the stage but actually to try to
collaborate with the team just to learn
and and hopefully have a different role
outside of that you've kind of had more
of that you do the same thing where
you're not just yeah i'll write the
music for you and go away you like to be
a part of the team you like to think
about design so you've probably been
privy to some of these conversations too
and
and some of this math that i learned on
a recent call was just mind-blowing to
me and you're like yeah it's about how
it works
do you see this like
what i'm talking about as far as the
landscape changing you were kind of like
yeah this is that that would be
considered a big success but what has
your experience been for some of these
smaller because you do a lot of times
work with you work with triple a's but
you also work with smaller studios as
well
what are they hoping to achieve what is
their like benchmark for success and
you've worked with those who have had
sequels so
i'm curious what your experience has
been yeah it's
mike definitely said it best when saying
that it's pretty hard to generalize
because
like i've worked on games
i don't want to speak out of turn so
i'll be super broad and abstract but
i've worked on games
assassin's
[Laughter]
is actually an interesting one because
they
they
um
basically the three principals who
started that company
effectively lived off savings paid
themselves nothing did a kickstarter
that they raised like three quarters of
a million dollars
put that towards the hard costs outside
of their own
like they paid themselves nothing they
just they owned the company so they they
just basically were were hoping to
have the game succeed and that was going
to be their income
and um
hiring sound design and actors and
obviously they
empowered me to hire a great big
orchestra in dallas uh speaking of and
um myerson's a beautiful place isn't it
it was pretty awesome uh and so
um
they
their metric for success was
can a second can can the income from
this
finance a sequel because the kickstarter
always propositioned it as a trilogy
and so they knew that they had more
story to tell if they should be so lucky
and so it was like
you know
can we basically make enough money to do
all this again
but
without like
now we need now it needs to be uh enough
of a threshold that our bills are like
we're now paying ourselves as a as a
team because we can basically bootstrap
through the development of of of one
game but you can't just go unpaid
forever like they they all had families
and kids and
you know like they they so
the metric for them was definitely real
cash
um and then but i've worked on other
projects
um where
you know they made these kinds of
platform deals and things like you're
talking about i've worked on games where
they were profitable before one unit had
sold
and so
it it didn't happens a lot because
because a platform will pay we'll have a
conversation offline about it but the
platforms will pay you to be on their
platform for example sometimes i
understand
i got you we understand that your budget
is x one million dollars we'll give you
three million dollars if you give us
exclusivity
gotcha and then you're profitable before
anyone actually actually i was going to
say i think weirdly if if you're looking
for like the metric of the popularity of
the game rather than necessarily how
much money it made i think austin might
be saying on the best and possible
metrics because i reckon your album
sales austin are very indicative of
popularity like whether because i i but
not profitability because i bet some of
your albums that don't have as many like
listeners on them
made more money because of these kind of
business models or whatever you're
speaking with
basically i reckon you could definitely
like look at your listener numbers and
you could you could glean a lot about
whatever something's connected no you
you can absolutely there's a really
strong corollary
between you know like spotify
i mean
it's a little messy because sometimes a
really well positioned playlist with a
huge number of followers will will grab
one of your tracks and then but that
still speaks to that point though
there's a popularity to where
even if it's derivative essentially
derivative content right
um
you understand that the music is a part
of the thing but as far as where you saw
it as like a second window thing if
taylor swift goes oh my god i just
played banner song and i love the music
and i've been listening to this and bam
it blows up that's not necessarily
saying that people are going to go buy
the game but they might listen to the
music so the ip has popularity that
extends beyond the sale of a game
yeah but i do think in general
um
like
all i meant by the playlisting thing is
i'll look at
break like there's one track in the
middle of banner saga one that has way
more streams per month than the rest and
it's because it's sitting on someone's
like really popular d and d playlist or
something like that you know like sure
they don't even necessarily know what
it's from
um and a lot of the people who come and
listen to that they want like cool moody
you know quasi medieval d d music or
whatever and and they don't even
necessarily look to see what's playing
on that play there's like 200 tracks or
whatever but it's there's tens of
thousands of people that listen to that
playlist every day or whatever so but
that's why they're like for like like
yeah
those outliers will happen but i bet
still over enough time
and enough like noise i i bet that's i
bet it's still indicating it is
interesting i mean journey is far and
away my most popular album but i bet you
never heard it i bet you like probably i
would guess assassin's creed is the best
selling game that i've scored yeah they
would have made the most they would have
made the most money probably um and uh
but it's hard to say you know i mean
there's been a few
like monaco was a kind of similar
situation to thomas was alone in so far
as you know it
through the course of of uh generally
good sales being at that same window of
time
humble and all that it's millions of
units and on and on yeah
i also want to point out something that
you uh based on the conversation awesome
that you and i had to anybody who is um
wanting to make their own game and and
like willing to bootstrap it and do
whatever it takes and you know eat ramen
until they make it
something that we heard from uh
very successful people in the business
who have watched
games small games be successful and fail
said the notion of i won't you know i
won't even take a salary is actually to
people who want to give you money a red
flag
yeah that's that was a a big mindset
people who dm you saying i'll come work
for you for free it's like no because i
need you i need this to be the only
thing that you do it's not like now go
watch dishes
value yourself as well right absolutely
yeah and that even means you know mike
you've taken this position before he's
like i'm the
this is my ship essentially i have a lot
of people that work for me and a lot of
people on my ship that are that are
helping me get this from one
this ship from one shore to the other
but
ultimately they eat before i do
um yeah but at the same time it's like
yeah but the captain can't be starving
the captain needs to be able to eat
but but yeah you definitely yeah you you
prioritize but you're right like yeah
that's and you but you wouldn't want to
be on the ship with the captain who was
starving right that's a bad [ __ ]
uh um our flag means death and man what
just a great again another i'm i'm so
one of the things that i love most about
flying again is just the the tv that i
can watch again yeah yeah you can catch
up on stuff yeah i've been telling
austin i don't know mike if you've
watched it but for all mankind is a
really really clever show you are the
second person to recommend that show to
me today all right like it's did it just
have like a new season or something yeah
like it seems like season three just
dropped uh there's and they're they're
going back to you know even or
event-based event-based viewing so a new
episode drops for at least us on friday
but it's very very clever the thing that
i uh commend them for doing
is they're doing this interstitial
content to where it's like you know two
to three minute pieces of like newscast
and it's a period piece and in the same
vein of like uh the americans or a man
in the high castle
um to where it's it's you know framing
it with an alternate history but they
will do these like new cat newscasts of
actual stories and i didn't realize that
they're actually real
historical events like i didn't realize
that there was a russian
um
fighter that shot down a korean
uh commercial airline
and 269 people died on board this is
like the height of the cold war and they
used that within their fiction but then
they also completely juxtapose it um and
have people that are like oh no that
person died like no they're still alive
um but it's it's a wonderful premise and
it's done it's done very very well um
it's got incredible performances some
are little soap opery and and you know
it is it is that it's always plot driven
but yeah i've really loved it really
enjoyed it it's definitely on the list
yeah yeah like i said it's coming it's
people are i think i watched like the
first few episodes and fell off it but
like a couple of people have like in the
last week suggested to me so i didn't
need to get to it it's everyone was like
what am i watching in the world okay now
lincoln lawyer because it's my guilty
pleasure book series that they find
there's a book series about called the
lincoln lawyer that i've always been a
fan of and there's a netflix show now
that is trash wasn't that the moment
with matthew mcconaughey that was based
on agriculture yeah and that's now and
that's canon so it's not it's not it's
not a grisham book it's um michael
connolly oh yeah but in the books
that movie canonically exists and the
character is annoyed that they made a
movie about him so it's like a role
there's it's if you're if you're into
like trashy airport november
[Music]
i was clive kessler i was clive kessler
and there was like there's a few others
that i dan brown of course i [ __ ]
burned through that
um i i loved those um so you're fair so
did he
[ __ ]
not a man who did a second pass on any
of those
we stayed
we like cogently discussed
some proper
topical cogent is uh maybe a little
i think we should be interested in might
be overstated at this point
maybe like we all had saline
we hit on insect viagra we
uh i learned some new things milk dairy
production
we started off with you know wistful
nostalgia that's summer that's topical
went into like the game that's really
pinging right now she's gonna be so
proud of us
she's going to be really proud of us we
did well apparently she messaged me
we did a really good job what'd she say
that's she messages
mom's not coming to pick us up after
soccer practice is that what she says
exactly we did we had a lot of fun
um who's gonna do it you should i feel
like you [ __ ] may have never
have you
i always [ __ ] it up i don't do good with
indoors and outros i really don't well
you know what the three of us do you
know our names you've got all the
information you just pull up my
wikipedia
real quick
um hey everybody uh i'm troy baker that
is wrong that god damn it i don't why is
it so weird just fix it just make it
right
see that's mike bithell uh he is a brit
no
video game
developer is that what you say writer
director what are you using what do we
say
that's awesome
he's a video game composer uh and alana
pierce is our soccer mom and she's not
picking us up after soccer um we're
walking home tonight thank you go go
wishlist something on steam today help
uh help an indie developer out do find
find one that's just shitty and and has
no nothing and go make their day and go
wishlist
and if you don't want to wish list all
my games are in a sale on steam right
now i said something shitty i covered it
you did i covered it too by
self-promotion it's the perfect system
uh we'll hopefully see you all next week
you know i
don't know if there's video for this one
what why would there be videos
oh my god
another lost episode no we have audio
holy [ __ ] that's amazing
i'm gonna get onto that animator you
stop recording i'm gonna stop recording